I know but stay vid coma isn't it so fun
always like you've always got a fan
moment or a ruffle moment you loved a
little bit this was kind of giving me
some violet chachki realness kind of you
know well here's my question for you you
always work the red carpet now you have
a casual 500 Grammys where did you put
all the Grammys well I'm gonna give one
to my grandma one day my mama put one on
the hood of my car you know so everybody
knows um yeah I don't know I was like I
have a really small house and I have
like very limited books book space but I
do have a framed joint given to me by a
Willie Nelson so I mean it seems like
kind of a nice place to put it
next to that that's an iconic statue
next to an iconic framed piece of art I
love how you said so everybody knows
because how about how David Crosby just
like discovered your I left how playful
you were about it was just cute it was
just really cute I mean look I'm at this
point so used to having my name is
spelled it is nothing new but I just
kind of just I just found the humor in
social media really and he's awesome you
know after the Grammys the big topic of
discussion for all of us was this woman
has made so many waves in country music
already
now she's won Album of the year it's
awesome like how does it feel to you
that people are talking about you and
the framework of finally a woman in
country music getting the attention that
is deserved for women this album is very
personal to me and I just feel like the
people who have connected with it have
just shown it so much love and so much
positivity it's just gone and done
things that I just really I just could
have never dreamed of and it just makes
me really happy it represents a really a
beautiful time in my life full of lots
of change and you know I just want to
keep doing what I'm doing the music
makes me feel good and I'm just really
happy that I made other people feel good
we have a little game we're playing
called eat eat up or somebody teased up
a question for you right before you get
up here t-pain teed up for you what is
your recipe for macaroni and cheese oh
man you know what I love a lobster mac
and cheese lobster mac and cheese are
like a green chili mac like something a
little spicy thrown in there like if I
was gonna have a cheat day like that
would be on my list do you get a cheat
day often um okay so after the Grammys
and the little Oscars part bit and then
I had had four shows at the Ryman in
Nashville which was really awesome you
know hometown shows and then I finally
was like I'm getting my damn cheat day
so I post mated from bed pizza and a
burger at the same time and then like I
ate that and then for dinner had some
pasta I like carved out it was I was
kind of tear in the handfuls of gummy
bear it's just a handful painful
[Music]
[Applause]